hey youtubers is Charlie so I had a
chance to finish iron fist so I wanted
to do a video to address some of the
issues I think it had and how they can
fix that in season two there's going to
be a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
happening if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get it and click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss out on anything it's going to be
great but there were a couple key issues
that I had with iron fist I don't think
it's complete trash like a lot of
critics said they're really like four
key areas that I feel like they could
have done so much better the biggest
complaint is that they could have done
better given the stuff they've done
before so one we have to talk about the
story - we have to talk about the
characters three we have to talk about
the music and four we have to talk about
their execution of the martial arts so I
think I can do most of this without
doing crazy spoilers for the later
episodes but later in the video when I
do have to address specific things I'll
try to give spoiler warnings just in
case so the story I think they suffer
from a lot of Iron Man two problems only
crammed into a much shorter amount of
time so you wind up with kind of like
six episodes of story stretched out into
13 episodes there are a lot of people
who responded to this with like hey you
know why didn't they do eight episodes
of Luke Cage eight episodes of iron fist
and then 13 episodes of defenders the
big crazy Avenger style team-up that
we've all been waiting for instead of
the other way around
there's only eight episodes of defenders
so iron fist starts off with the whole
mystery about who is Danny ran proving
his identity they spend way too much
time drawing that out what I would have
rather has seen is him just step onto
the scene within the first episode maybe
one and a half episodes then decide okay
this is Danny Rand he's the iron fist
and then immediately within that first
arc start pursuing the big goal of
taking down the hand he says he's the
mortal enemy of the hand the hand is
sort of presented as the Netflix's
version of Hydra so crazy organization
that crosses over between all the show's
surfaces all the biggest villains and
serves as the source of some of the more
mystical things that they've introduced
in what is otherwise a very street-level
real world universe so they spend a
little too much time on the real world
trying to prove Danny's identity before
they really push into the cool Iron Fist
mythology and the stuff that you really
want to see and even though the back
half of the season does make up for some
of the lack of plot in Luke
cages back half of the season that was
even more plotless than Iron Fist
it still meanders through about eight
episodes of plot in 13 episodes so they
really should just shorten the episode
count the real problem I think is in how
they set all these shows up the way they
issued the contracts when Netflix made
the deal with Marvel initially they
contracted them to do Iron Fist
daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage then
the defenders team-up within a certain
period of time in sometimes you just
need more time to figure a show out to
train the cast to do the really crazy
action scenes so I think they had a lot
more time to figure out daredevil before
they actually shot that show and it has
the benefit of being first so it's like
if there were any problems they had time
to work them out before season 2 so by
the time you get to the fifth season of
a Netflix show remember there were two
seasons of daredevil already you expect
it to be just so much better than
everything else that came before but
when they rush things a little bit or
they don't trust themselves to change
the story to make certain elements
better like they changed some of
Daredevils comic book story and I think
they didn't trust themselves as much
with changing the Iron Fist comic book
story there were a couple of key comic
book changes that I'll explain when I do
a more spoilery explainer video for the
ending of the series there were some
interesting things that they did I love
the comic book stuff that they did but
moving on to the characters so one of
the biggest problems I think that it
suffers from is that you don't really
understand what Danny Rance motivation
is at the very beginning why did he
leave Kunlun
you almost don't find that out at all
they sort of imply what that reason is
towards the end of the series when a
couple other characters come in but they
never outright tell you and even if
you've read the comics you know his
origin story you can make some guesses
as to why that was but the TV show
shouldn't make you have to read the
comics in order to understand character
motivation they should spell that out
it's a very beginning like the opening
scene should tell you everything you
need to know about the character and
they just don't do that so he doesn't
get the character development that he
needs so it's really hard to understand
who Danny Rand is especially if you
haven't read the comics then we got to
talk about the Meacham's
so they spend way too much time with
these characters in RAND Corporation
which is arguably the least important
part of what this series should be
reincorporation
is almost meaningless to Danny he uses
it to do the things
he wants to do but he doesn't like
spending time there it's not like he
really enjoys being in a boardroom so I
like where they got these characters to
but for like the first half of the
season warden Meacham was almost like
this mustache twirling villain he
doesn't get more complicated and
interesting till way later in the series
the same thing happens for joy Meacham
they leave her in this really
interesting place like you're really
excited for her in season two but you're
never really sure how she feels about
Danny or all this other stuff that's
going on she's so tied up with the RAND
Corporation storyline and that's like
the least important part of the series
so what I'm hoping for season two is
they just get rid of most of those
corporate scenes and they allow these
characters to mix with the more mystical
elements of Danny ran Colleen wing was a
great character but she's so
underwritten because they spend so much
time at RAND Corporation early on and
she has very little to do with that
storyline so I think she was a victim of
that Claire temple was fantastic I love
rosario Dawson in all the series some of
the best moments were of the two of them
just doing things on their own moving on
to the music so while I didn't expect
the music to be quite as good as the
music of Luke Cage there was just like a
level of authorship with that series the
way the showrunner talked about how
important music was to the character to
the community of Harlem they did such a
good job of fitting the music into the
context of the scenes that were
happening the character arcs and I feel
like that just didn't happen for Iron
Fist the music always felt like some
ancillary things that they just added on
so moving on to the last thing and this
is probably most comic book fans biggest
complaint with the series that I think
they can totally fix for season two is
the martial arts so they do a lot of
cool things they did like a transporter
ax fight they did some it man they did
kisses a dragon they did drunken master
they did Bruce Lee Enter the Dragon in
the raid all these crazy awesome action
martial arts films but it feels like
they rushed every aspect of the
production of this series like oh my god
we got to get it out on time so maybe
they didn't have enough time to train
the actors to make them look like they
could fake these amazing martial arts
sequences nobody expects an actor to be
as good as Bruce Lee like unless you're
Donnie Yen that's just not going to
happen but what you want is for them to
be able to lock the camera off or a
crazy fight scene and then cut to their
faces for
actions later you don't want all the
cuts that they had to put in this and
usually they do that to hide stunt
doubles if all they had a lot of cool
ideas I feel like what will happen is is
by the time we get to season two they'll
just keep these actors training
year-round so that the martial arts are
way way better when we come back just
for example here's a little bit of the
hallway fight the example of you know
the hatchet transporter fight that they
were trying to do as well as the drunken
master fight which I actually feel was
creatively a little bit more interesting
honestly I feel like even if this story
isn't the best story ever as long as you
can nail the martial arts because iron
fist should be the most skilled martial
artist in the Marvel Universe next to
Shane Chi depending on how you feel
about that
so when you see martial arts like this
you're like hey what happened this is
supposed to be super badass like even if
you don't care what the story is you
should have the most amazing fight
sequences into the Badlands is a really
good example of a series that has like a
pretty okay story but the martial arts
and the fight sequences are amazing so
if they can do that on cable television
and they spend twice as much making the
Netflix series they should have the time
and the money to get it right but again
I didn't hate the series I just feel
like they could have done a way better
job with it and there's all problems
they can totally fix by season two but
let me know in the comments what were
your biggest issues with this series and
what's going to happen I know you have a
lot of questions about the ending all
the Easter eggs how this fits into the
Marvel Universe all do those videos next
week after more people have a chance to
watch the series but no worries there
was a lot of really cool stuff they did
towards the end of the series so I'll
try to get those videos out as fast as
possible but we got Walking Dead coming
up next and I'll post updates about the
video schedule in the comments so just
check the top pin comic that I post
while you wait for that click here for
new black panther footage and click here
for new guardians of the galaxy to
footage thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video